vamos ahora con revista de prensa ya
está conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez es
más de euros a bienvenida feliz
miércoles para ti muy buen día vamos a
empezar hablando entonces de las
elecciones en eeuu abrimos con el 'new
york times' klein young kim gana las
elecciones a gobernador en el estado de
virginia golpeando a los demócratas
porque nos golpea rosa buenos días raúl
exacto hemos querido fijarnos en la
portada que llevaba el 'new york times'
en su edición digital porque hay un
contraste entre las dos caras de la
moneda de esta jornada electoral la de
ayer y en el sabor de boca de boca que
deja a los distintos partidos porque si
bien nos empezamos fijando en los
resultados en la alcaldía de nueva york
donde el demócrata eric adams ganó y se
convirtió en el alcalde número 110 de la
ciudad y dentro de entre estos 110
alcaldes con los que ha contado en nueva
york' es solamente el segundo
afroestadounidense en ocupar el cargo y
precisamente por eso entre otras cosas
pues ha centrado su campaña en la racial
no recordemos también que es ex agente
de policía pero la otra cara de la
moneda la que tenemos pues aquí arriba
es la que quizás se preocupa más a la
actual administración estadounidense al
gobierno de joe biden no porque estas
elecciones en el estado de virginia lo
que fueron a claves para la victoria
demócrata de bailén suponen un revés no
para el actual gobierno porque de hecho
el propio presidente de byd en desde
glasgow donde se encontraba para asistir
a la cob aseguró que iban a ganar la
gobernación de este estado algo que pues
sea finalmente no ha sido así recordemos
así doblen yongqing como comentaba este
empresario de 54 años ex ejecutivo
financiero que un multimillonario que
con su propio dinero ha financiado gran
parte de su campaña y que pues se ha
convertido en actual gobernador del
estado de virginia y ahora de hecho
vamos a centrarnos en lo que supone esta
victoria republicana así es y por qué
los demócratas están entonces en
problemas es un artículo opinión que
escribió grande stevens exacto este
artículo pues lo que comentábamos no
intenta analizar que debe hacer ahora el
partido demócrata para poder sobrellevar
esta situación y cambiar un poco el
escenario de cara a poder seguir
adelante con la legislatura por un lado
señala esto no que hay 10 puntos de
diferencia en los resultados del estado
de virginia respecto a las
presidenciales del año anterior no no se
trata del mismo tipo de elecciones pero
pues así que sirve para comparar un poco
el estado de opinión en esa región y
precisamente dice que se ha basado mucho
esta campaña en la oposición ideológica
del candidato demócrata respecto al
republicano que los demócratas en los
demócratas intentaban pintar a glen
unión quin como un sucesor de trump
mientras que precisamente el candidato
republicano pues prometió ciertas
políticas reales así lo describe este
artículo cómo bajar los impuestos o que
hubiera más intervención de los padres
en la educación obligatoria con todo el
tema de las mascarillas etcétera de
hecho el ganador el candidato
republicano
insistía en oponerse a la que se llama
teoría crítica de la raza que vincula
pues la época de la esclavitud
esclavización de los afrodescendientes
con el acto el actual racismo
institucional pues de hoy en día y de
hecho pues esto hyun kim se opone a esta
esta corriente de pensamiento y también
no decía cosas como que pues en los
demócratas si van a educar y a convertir
a los hijos de los estadounidenses en
transgéneros continuamos entonces y
analizando estas elecciones en eeuu
vamos con the economics de republicano
green young quien gana las elecciones de
gobernador en virginia también lo reseña
este este medio es exacto y pues plantea
un poco cuál puede ser el escenario de
cara a las mil ternas en las elecciones
legislativas de medio término porque va
a ir en cuenta ahora con una muy baja
popularidad no y señalan que ésta caída
de la imagen de baile es una de las
cosas que ha podido afectar al candidato
demócrata en virginia de hecho según los
datos de the economist hay más
estadounidenses que desaprueban la
gestión de byd en que no que la aprueban
y de hecho dicen que hay muchas personas
que votaron por byd en que ahora han
votado por jon que en el candidato
republicano y que los demócratas tienen
que encontrar la manera para
volver a animar a alentar la
participación entre su electorado y
déjame que te lea la conclusión de este
artículo dice los resultados de virginia
confirman la triste convicción
republicana que librar la guerra
cultural es la forma de ganar los
demócratas se enfrentan a cuestiones
urgentes sobre cómo aumentar la
participación de entre sus votantes en
las ciudades y convencer a los
independientes ya los menos fieles en
las áreas más despobladas y finalizamos
rózsa con el south china morning post'
los asiáticos estadounidenses hacen
historia con las victorias en las
elecciones municipales exacto este
artículo se refiere aquí la vemos en mi
celular que se convierte en la alcaldesa
de boston y por otro lado también hasta
préval que se convierte en el alcalde de
cincinnati en el estado de ohio y lo que
señala este artículo es que ambos tal y
como relataron en distintas entrevistas
se encontraron con varios obstáculos no
relacionados con el racismo anti
asiático en sus carreras políticas y de
hecho les llegaron a desalentar no en
sus campañas hacia hacia las respectivas
alcaldías y de hecho un dato interesante
que lleva este texto es que menos del 1
por ciento de los cargos electos están
ocupados por estadounidenses de origen
asiático señala este artículo que es
precisamente de un medio chino que está
es una victoria contra el racismo anti
asiático precisamente así es rosa
gracias entonces por toda la información
nos vemos mañana con más revista de
prensa vamos ahora con nuestro primer
invitado del día